ah nirvana hey guys cambree Annie Johnny
no I don't plan to buy anything here I
bite my burger and agree dance at food
and stuff a discount food outlet
equidistant from my home in my work I
came here for the same reason people go
to the zoo Shh look at that thing
nature is amazing would you like to
sample our vegan bacon 100% meatless yes
please
another please
sir is there a problem I'm just making
sure no one ever has to eat this I don't
think I can give you any more I want one
ladies and gentlemen we are gathered
here today to answer an age-old question
right
what's Amy's deal she's single no we're
dating come on the question is who here
does the best impression of captain
Raymond Holt you'll be judged on voice
body language and overall lack of flair
everyone will perform the same scenario
captain Holt eating a marshmallow for
the very first time let the whole table
begin
what is this glutinous monstrosity
before me sugar and this is quite sweet
that's your Holt impression I can hear
him doing that looks like a sticky
pillow I don't care for it classical
music what's going on here what are you
doing captain hey nothing just eating
some marshmallows care for one
marshmallow I know it so while they
repaint the lines in the parking lot
we're asking everyone to do street
parking
I'm not street parking my Mercedes well
everyone is I'm doing it because nobody
wants to steal a Saturn all right moving
on to recycling you okay run just a
little tooth pain I'm fine continue okay
each department will be getting blue
bins do you need to go to the dentist
run I don't like dentists just a second
[Applause]
oh I'm sorry everybody what were we
talking about recycling dentist pulled
the tooth out yesterday but it's always
a good idea to demonstrate to your
co-workers that you are capable of
withstanding a tremendous amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see Tom faint
hello it's with the cast I sprained my
wrist oh no what happened don't worry
about it
I'm fine yeah geez Amy back off leave
the guy alone all right huddle up
everybody
bring it in bring it so he wouldn't say
what happened which can only mean one
thing
he's in a Fight Club no he did it doing
something he's embarrassed by like
smiling only question is how do you hurt
your arm smiling could be a sports
injury I sprained my wrist in college
playing field hockey
Bin's field hockey yeah it's much more
violent than the women's game we're not
allowed to wear anything that protects
our breasts attention everyone
I can hear you speculating about the
nature and origin of my injury from my
office I tripped over an uneven sidewalk
I did not think it was relevant to your
jobs the jobs which you should all be
doing right now get to work
do you want to know how I actually heard
- yes
I was looking Kevin and I attend a class
for fitness and for fun oh my god I've
mastered all the moves the pizza toss
the tornado the Scorpion the oopsie
doodle why are you telling me this
because no one will ever believe you
know it's rough in here is it always
like this
I wouldn't know don't like strip clubs
smells like a wet mop in here and I get
the feeling that every one of these
women is running a low-grade fever
you're one of the good ones run wait a
minute
hello you don't care
strippers do nothing for me I like a
strong salt-of-the-earth self-possessed
woman at the top of her field your
Steffi Graf's your Sheryl Swoopes is but
I will take a free breakfast buffet
anytime anyplace
I'm tired of politics let's get that
punk blood so this is amazing
of course we have no idea where he is
but I love where your head's at you have
no family maybe there was a girlfriend
or someone he worked with at the coffee
shop at the coffee shop why would
someone who knows they have 21 million
dollars coming take a minimum-wage job
because he needed access to that
building because that's where the
money's hidden all right we gotta get
there quick maybe we should take the
chopper death blade Sidewinder it's go
time
Roger that wet blankets no from now on
call me velvet I got a second box of
doughnuts if anybody what this this mr.
director is your new desk okay this desk
is the epitome of the Swedish concept of
a young stud ducked or equality imagine
someone needs your attention somebody
say my name Chris swivel what is Jerry
you told me to say your name and you did
a great job superstar someone else say
something you look like a freak swivel
April that is not a very good attitude I
will keep my eye on you from my circular
desk where I can see everything
tiny swivel see how it works what about
my office and its many walls that
becomes a new public waiting room and we
got rid of that giant pillar that was in
front of your door
I loved that pillar and made it really
annoying to stand in my doorway get over
it
cuz it's gone you're gonna be more
accessible than ever it will be had that
usage report that I asked for
[Music]
anything for you Gerry
thank you oh come on
why excuse me there's a sign at ramsett
park that says do not drink the
sprinkler water so I made some tea with
it and now I have an infection sir sir
are are you are you are you listening to
me sir sir I'm talking to you sir sir
are you aware that there is waste in
your water system I don't know what's
going on down at police headquarters and
no one will tell me anything so you're
saying that not knowing what your bosses
are up to it's driving you a little
crazy you've used my logic against me
well played Timmy well played thank you
sir
look at that you helped me find my smile
my name is Ron Swanson I'm here to tell
you about a black-tie gala fundraiser
for Pawnee Commons happening tonight all
proceeds will go toward building a park
it will be enjoyable now I will take
your calls apparently yes
hey Joan settle a bet for me who's the
sexiest couple in history our paths in
case dew or Bieber shouldn't you be
taking her to lie down somewhere
no no if she ever found out that we took
her off camera we'd all be fired so just
keep taking phone calls you're doing
great three hello again
I'm Ron Swanson and I am still taking
your calls hopefully about tonight's
gala you're on the air hi what's wrong
with Joan she has a bad hangover which
she is pretending as allergies is she
gonna be okay wouldn't know never been
hungover after I've had too much whiskey
I cooked myself a large flank steak
pan-fried and salted butter
I eat that put on a pair of wet socks
and go to sleep that works it does
please call now if you have questions
about tonight's gala or one of my other
interests woodworking
novels about tall ships meat that sort
of thing
this is run go ahead call her hi my
Yorkshire Terrier has chewed up the legs
on my kitchen table is there a cheap way
to repair that great question
take a wall nut and rub it into the legs
of your table that'll mask the scratches
next thing you want to do is ditch the
Terrier and get yourself a proper dog
any dog under fifty pounds is a cat and
cats are pointless the math thing isn't
the problem nightshifts keeping you and
Kevin apart you two just need a bone
I said you two need a bone Oh dare you
detective Diaz I am your superior
officer what happens in my bedroom
detective is none of your business don't
ever speak to me like that again
I hate that dude his pen up no he knows
problem-solving
you